le rassemblement national ainsi que la
france insoumise qui sont les seuls
partis politiques qui se sont très
réticentes sur la tenue de ce scrutin
dès le départ
voyez ce qu'en dit michel larive à
député la france insoumise de l'ariège
nous sommes engagés encore là en ce
moment au second tour dans plus de 200
liste souvent soutien des listes
citoyenne que nous avons très souvent
initiés fin dans certaines villes comme
amiens marseille toulouse je vais pas
toutes les citer mais je cite celle là
mettre en place ce que nous développons
vous dans notre programme l'avenir en
commun c'est-à-dire en proximité m usd
des politiques sociales rêve écologique
il ya des pratiques qui peuvent être
changées dans les communautés et aussi
surtout dans les intercommunalités ce
que doit savoir aussi vos
téléspectateurs c'est que ces élections
vont aussi avoir un impact sur les
communautés de communes et les
communautés d'agglomération c'est là où
son véritable monneret centres de
décision c'est pour ça que je crois que
il faut se déplacer malgré le contexte